d'où seulement car s'adresse aux
militants socialistes réunis en
université d'été le premier ministre
fait face à la nervosité sociale de
septembre et à une contestation dans les
rangs ps henri krasucki est notre invité
la cgt le pc mobilisent contre le
gouvernement rocard le pc qui veut punir
contre le recul social
la mort de deux policiers du raid puis à
ris orangis par un forcené illustre la
difficulté de ce type d'intervention de
boulaq et la transparence
une équipe d'antenne de rentrer de
sibérie deux mille cinq cents
prisonniers sont détenus aux contraintes
de ce sont les droits communs dit on
l'abat reportage exclusif de michel
morin et d'alain poirier
madame monsieur bonsoir un spectaculaire
carambolage a eu lieu tout à l'heure sur
l'autoroute a6 une cinquantaine de
voitures ont été endommagées
il y a une dizaine de blessés c'est pour
nous l'occasion de vous rappeler que ce
week end est le dernier des retours de
vacances
vous serez 5 millions sur les routes
attendez si possible dimanche ou lundi
pour rentrer le fort chabrol de ris
orangis a donc mal tourné hier soir le
forcené a tué deux policiers du raid qui
venait de pénétrer dans son appartement
par la fenêtre un inspecteur
divisionnaire et un sous-brigadier deux
autres policiers ont également été
grièvement blessé le forcené
gravement blessé à lui été hospitalisé
ce drame illustre la difficulté de ce
type d'intervention hervé brusini il
aura fallu quatre heures de face à face
deux assauts pour qu'enfin gérard
marillier blessé à la poitrine lâche son
arme il n'était pas question pour lui
d'accepter d'être placé en hôpital
psychiatrique
alors son appartement avait pris des
allures de bunker pour réussir leur
intervention les hommes du raid devait
entrer simultanément par la fenêtre et
par le palier mais l'obstacle était là
laporte a résisté aux explosifs
il est vrai qu'elle était d'un type de
blindage que nous ne connaissions pas
mais je crois que personne n'aurait pu
nous donner plus de détails sur ce type
de blanc d'oeuf
c'est effectivement un des éléments qui
ont fait je crois le plus important qui
ont fait que malheureusement cette
affaire passée dérouler de cette façon
de toute façon la vie continue et que
malheureusement ce type de drame
je voulais 10 est à la fois la tristesse
lorsqu'on drame arrive et la grandeur de
notre service ça ne peut pas remettre en
cause son temps fondamentalement les
méthodes de travail
c'est simplement que des enseignements
seront tirés de cette affaire comme des
enseignements ont été tirés de toutes
les affaires précédentes des affaires
nombreuses depuis dix ans c'est la
gendarmerie qui la première a acquis
avec le gign l'expérience de ce type
d'intervention en moyenne une
quarantaine d'actions chaque année mais
aucune ne se ressent il faut traiter au
cas par cas
les grands principes sont pourtant ému à
localiser le forcené évoluer son état
nerveux discuter avec lui profité d'une
accalmie pour passer à l'action
or tout cela n'a pas été possible à ris
orangis pourquoi y at il eu erreur ou un
ton d'érable les hommes du raid doivent
maintenant répondre précisément à cette
question ce soir force ouvrière police
s'interroge sur la responsabilité de
ceux qui ont permis à un individu
dépressif de se constituer à domicile un
véritable arsenal de guerre
le syndicat appelle à une meilleure
réglementation de la vente d'armes
michel rocard devant l'université d'été
du ps appelle les militants à se
rassembler dans la confiance et dans la
détermination il fallait une philosophie
gouvernementale pour les prochains mois
elle tient en trois mots pacte de
croissance à risoul dans les
hautes-alpes pour antenne 2 jean-michel
mercurol très attendus michel rocard à
risoul par les militants d'abord tous
courants confondus mais aussi par les
orateurs qui de lionel jospin jean
poperen se sont tous contentés d'une
réserve prudente avant la rentrée
politique du premier ministre avant les
éclaircissements attendu de lui sur le
partage des fruits de la croissance
le partage oui répond michel rocard mais
sans compromettre jamais le fragile
équilibre économique chômage et commerce
extérieur reste nos deux handicaps
on ne peut on ne doit pas et je sais que
nul ici nous sommes socialistes que nul
ici ne voudraient distribuer du pouvoir
d'achat supplémentaire dans une société
où intense le chômage s'aggrave alors
même que tout le monde voudrait y
poussent les chômeurs n'ont pas le droit
de grève des chômeurs n'ont pas de
partie
les chômeurs n'ont pas de syndicats le
gouvernement et les socialistes s'ils ne
sont heureusement par les seuls doivent
toujours être les premiers à se
préoccuper de la répartition doit donc
tenir compte d'une croissance assez
réelle il soit possible d'offrir un
emploi au moins à tous les jeunes ils
sont 170 mille arrivent chaque année sur
le marché du travail
nous y sommes à peu près cette année je
n'imagine pas qu'il y ait un socialiste
qui puisse concevoir un autre ordre de
brio
la priorité c'est l'emploi dit le
premier ministre qui propose de
redistribuer les richesses en trois
volets un tiers pour l'emploi un tiers
pour la formation et l'investissement
enfin seulement un tiers pour le pouvoir
d'achat du secteur public
bref un pacte de croissance proposé au
pays par delà les socialistes de risoul
et socialiste michel rocard voudrait
voir heureux une perspective qui selon
lui constitue le douzième des travaux
d'hercule invités de ce journal monsieur
krasucki pour la cgt ne sut krasucki
est-ce que ce pacte de croissance vous
convient est-ce que partager le surplus
de richesse entre l'emploi
l'investissement et le pouvoir d'achat
vous convient c'est bien non des mots
des mots des mots ce n'est pas de moi
c'est facile de trouver ou formules
ronflantes qui sonne bien un pack de
croissance
c'est un guy champ mais les actes les
actes du gouvernement les actes de
michel rocard c'est sa lettre au pdg des
entreprises nationalisées à laquelle
participe le ministre des ptt ce qui
veut dire quelque chose pour leur dire
rien sur le pouvoir d'achat et cnpf a
très bien entendu pour ce qui concerne
le privé les adh c'est l'injustice qui
grandit et que les gens ressentent
pendant qu'ils perdent du pouvoir
d'achat et tous les ans les profits
c'est reconnu publiquement augmente il
flambe
s'il bat tous les records à quoi sert-il
alors et naturellement les salariés
disent
et nous et nous c'est valable pour tous
les salariés mais michel rocard lui il
dit il n'est pas question que je fasse
plus que ce que j'ai dit gérard leclerc
oui henri krasucki et le gouvernement
fait de l'emploi sa première priorité
avant le pouvoir d'achat est ce que ce
n'est pas normal dans un pays où il ya
deux millions et demi de chômeurs vous
savez les histoires de priorité je
trouve d'ailleurs un petit peu indécent
que l'on tente de dresser les chômeurs
contre les autres salariés parce que ce
ne sont pas les autres salariés qui crée
le chômage mais c'est parmi les salariés
qu'on fait des chômeurs et seront là il
s'appelle patronat et il s'appelle aussi
gouvernement quand celui qui responsable
parce que tout de même je voudrais bien
que l'on voit ceci c'est le titre d'un
journal économique déficit historique
des échanges on lui on lui assez mal
monsieur crédit échanges de l'industrie
civile française mais ce déficit là est
particulièrement sensible dans la
métallurgie dans la sidérurgie mais dans
l'ensemble des activités
d'où vient il on a fermé tant du sinn on
a cassé temps de capacités de production
on a mis à la porte en nombre qui sont
devenus des chômeurs et qu'on pleure
maintenant
et la france n'est plus en capacité de
fournir de produire ce dont elle a
besoin et ce qu'elle pourrait vendre
ailleurs aloi de l'acheter alors parler
de l'emploi sans faire une vraie
politique industrielle et sans faire une
vraie politique du développement du
service public
créateur d'emplois et utile pour les
gens ça n'a pas de sens
on nous a dit ça depuis des années alors
justement vous parlez de service public
modernisation du service public c'est
aussi une des priorités du gouvernement
monsieur krasucki est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le plan de modernisation
du service public de monsieur rocard
qu'est-ce que d'une voulu trouver sa
priorité en matière s'il en a une c'est
d'essayer de le disc jockey en tant que
service public et en tant que statut des
personnels des services publics
regardez quelques ce que les syndicats
tous protestent et à juste titre mais
surtout les salariés des différentes
branches du service public que ce soit
la fonction publique sur les postiers
que ce soit
d'autres services publics énergie
cheminots tous disent non enfin on a
moins de monde pour faire ce qu'il faut
il ya toutes les capacités
intellectuelles pour moderniser il ya
bien des choses qui sont très modernes
en france dans le service public
regardez le tgv mais derrière qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour le reste du chemin de
fer en france et et les accidents d'où
vient-il
il ya pas assez de monde pour
l'entretien et c'est la même chose donc
toute une série d'activités
alors maintenant on nous dit on veut
moderniser mais c'est le prétexte pour
aller encore plus en arrière pour non
seulement moins bien servir les gens
mais mieux plus mal traités
les personnels hors norme jolie pour
moderniser les pratiques et michel
rocard a relancé aujourd'hui l'idée de
l'intéressement c'est à dire de primes
liées à la croissance à l'efficacité des
entreprises publiques qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
je vais répondre à votre question permet
moi tu es 12 même de dire que vous avez
interrompu en trois minutes c'est
difficile de poser des questions les
nageuses
j'étais en train de répondre à une
question et ce n'est pas convenable de
m'avoir interrompue mais cela dit je
réponds à votre nouvelle question
l'intéressement que ce soit le service
public ou que sais tu aimes ce secteur
public privé on nous le ressert
périodiquement on l'a eue avec de gaulle
on a vu avec pompidou nous le revoilà
maintenant l'intéressement
c'est à la fois quelque chose qui va
contre directement l'intérêt des
salariés concernés et s'étonne du prix
pourquoi contre leurs intérêts mais
parce que c'est une part de leur salaire
qui devient incertaine qu'on leur donne
sans garantie on peut là leur reprendre
un jury yade l'autre ne lendemain ya pas
ça ne compte pas pour la sécurité
sociale après on dit qu'il ya pas de
déficit mais ça ne compte pas non plus
pour la retraite
on ne peut pas payer la retraite donc si
on a des petites retraites les salariés
y perdent mieux vaut être payé en un
salaire bien garantie claire que tout le
monde comprenne plutôt que sous cette
forme truqués est incertaine
d'autre part on prétend par ce moyen là
leur donner l'impression qu'ils sont
pour quelque chose dans l'est
entreprise alors qu'il le soit en
actionnant pour rien n'ont pas le droit
à la parole
ce qu'ils disent n'est pas entendue
hilton étant entendu que quand il se met
en colère regarder même des gendarmes
pour qu'ils soient entendus il a fallu
qu'ils fassent ça ce sont des militaires
organisés pour les sucres hazuki nous
vous remercions donc on peut supposer
après ce tout faux vous donner à
monsieur rocard que votre tonnes cgt ce
sera chaud en un mot parce que ce n'est
pas mon vocabulaire chaud froid météo
c'est pas moi c'est pas comme ça que
j'écris
monsieur mais la tribu mais par contre
ce que je peux vous dire
d'ailleurs vous dit lui même et toujours
le lez
ça va être animé ça commence c'est clair
c'est évident les gens en ont assez ils
ne croient plus sur parole et 10 ben on
en a tant entendu maintenant on va s'y
mettre nous mêmes
monsieur les outils monsieur krasucki
mars les pilotes du thé à l'appel du
syndicat national des pilotes de ligne
sont à nouveau en grève depuis la nuit
dernière et jusqu'à mardi 0 heure aucun
vol n'a pour l'instant été annulés sur
ce conflit à rebondissements
c'est la cinquième grève en trois mois
les explications d'alain noveski lutter
à verse à son personnel des salaires
proches de ceux des autres compagnies
aériennes en revanche hôtesses et
stewards sa filiale charters
aéromaritime eux sont payés beaucoup
moins aux tests débutant 6100 francs au
lieu de huit mille francs
question de survie affirme la direction
pour le personnel l'explication est
toute autre
la filiale aéromaritime serait une
machine de guerre créée pour faire
pression sur tous les salaires du groupe
d'ailleurs pour équilibrer leurs revenus
avec ceux de leurs collègues des ro
maritime hôtesses et stewards du téat
avait accepté les propositions d'un
médiateur davantage d'heures de travail
pour un salaire réduit de 5000 francs en
moyenne par an réponse la direction
c'est non elles jugent encore
insuffisants les efforts consentis par
le personnel pour les évaluent à environ
17% si on additionne les gains de
productivité les sacrifices en salaire
alors culte est rare nous demande selon
nos estimations entre 10 et 50 % de
gains de productivité et d'efforts
salariaux par rapport à la situation
actuelle
quant au pilote blocage également
il lutte contre l' embauche depuis les
étrangers moins bien payés aucun accord
n'étant but est l'objet d'arrêtés suite
sur un char permanente de la part de la
direction
nous n'arrivons pas à trouver un accord
durable dans l'esprit de son personnel
ut1 est un conflit test si la direction
parvient à baisser substantiellement les
salaires
les autres compagnies aériennes
s'inspireront de la méthode tous les
regards de l'aviation civile sont
braqués sur ut à la bataille autour du
groupe d'assurances se victoire continue
avec un nouvel épisode jean-marc verne
principal actionnaire renonce à lancer
une contre perf face aux raids menés par
suez il compte sur la fidélité de ses
partenaires pour conserver le contrôle
du groupe d'assurances victoire
la cotation de la compagnie industrielle
principal actionnaire du groupe victoire
a été suspendu aujourd'hui à la bourse
jusqu'à laisse jean marie le pen devant
l'université de son mouvement à la baule
fixe comme objectif à sa formation il
faut accéder au pouvoir
université d'été au cours de laquelle on
entend dire que le front national est le
dernier rempart contre le génocide
français à la baule pour antenne 2 bruno
roger-petit et philippe baroux le front
national est une grande famille où tout
le monde connaît tout le monde
mais jean marie le pen le chef de clan
aurait plutôt tendance en déduire que
c'est là un signe que le cercle de
famille est trop restreint résultats
afin d'attirer de nouvelles vocations
le front national se renforce transfuge
du rpr énarque de formation yvan blot
est venu apporter un nouveau souffle à
la doctrine du mouvement lepéniste
car le front national compte désormais
relancé la guerre idéologique à outrance
ainsi trois jours durant
les militants ont subi un entraînement
politico administratif que ne renierait
pas un candidat au concours d'entrée à
l'ena
les nappes façon front national c'est
l'avenir du parti qui est en jeu nous
n'aurons pas trop du temps qui nous est
laissé pour accomplir pour atteindre
l'objectif que nous nous sommes fixés à
savoir porter les idées de la droite
nationale au pouvoir dans le laps de
temps le plus court possible parce que
nous sommes conscients que dans une
période de décadence tout minute qui
passe est une minute perdre
contre la décadence le front national
prôné officiellement l'exclusion de tout
ce qui n'est pas français
une position qu'il est le seul parti à
défendre une position qui paradoxalement
pourrait faire des militants de jean
marie le pen des exclus du jeu politique
françois mitterrand en coup de vent pour
quelques heures ce margaret thatcher le
président français a rencontré le
premier ministre britannique dans sa
résidence d'été de checkers près de
londres
les discussions emporté largement sur
l'union politique économique et
monétaire de l'europe
la france est actuellement à la tête de
la cee l'angleterre soutient également
la france dans son action diplomatique
au liban les deux parties sont convenues
comme un pari d'hommes douleur du sommet
d industrialiser de faire de la lutte
contre la drogue l'une de leurs
priorités en espagne fort de son bon
résultat aux élections européennes le
premier ministre felipe gonzalez
convoque des élections parlementaires
anticipées pour le 29 octobre
huit mois avant la fin de la législature
pour gonzalez c'est l'espoir d'obtenir
une troisième victoire socialiste aux
législatives après sept ans de pouvoir
en pologne le 50e anniversaire de la
deuxième guerre mondiale il est marqué
cette année par un renouveau du dialogue
entre varsovie et bonne les polonais
apprennent également à réécrire leur
histoire pour la première fois cette
année a été critiquée officiellement
l'invasion soviétique de 1939 antenne 2
et en pologne
j'admire lino dominique merlin
il ya 50 ans un navire allemand le feu
sans sommation sur une garnison
polonaise
cela se passait à bester plater près de
danzig c'était le premier acte
d'agression de l'allemagne nazie et le
début de la seconde guerre mondiale la
pologne sera l'un des pays les plus
frappés par ce conflit 6 millions de ses
habitants
ils trouveront la molle pour commémorer
cet événement les polonais ont organisé
une série de manifestations qui vont
bien au-delà du simple souvenir car
depuis le changement de gouvernement et
la perte du pouvoir par les communistes
les polonais commence par et à prendre
leur passé c'est ainsi qu'hier soir
devant le général georges ce qui est le
premier ministre mazowiecki la mémoire
des trois mille officiers polonais
exécutés par des soviétiques à katyn fut
officiellement évoquée et l'ont rendu
hommage pour la première fois aux
combattants de l'armée nationale dont
les survivants seront exécutés par les
communistes polonais entre 1946 et 1958
plusieurs dizaines de milliers à être
tué son jugement est aujourd'hui dans
les cimetières polonais on commence à
dégager les simples pierre marquant leur
tombe ici une main anonyme a écrit priez
pour ceux qui sont tombés là caché dans
un recoin une grande croix de bois est
consacrée à la mémoire de toutes ces
victimes sur un papier protégés par du
plastique
on peut lire passants arrête ton pas et
pense à tous ceux qui ont été tués dans
la prison de moscou toof d'une balle
dans la nuque
ils ont été enterrés ici en secret il
voulait se battre jusqu'au bout
ils n'eurent ni fleurs des couronnes
passant n'oublie pas le climat n'est pas
à la sérénité en afrique du sud à
quelques jours des élections des
milliers de syndicalistes noir ont
entamé une campagne de désobéissance
civile à l'occasion d'une manifestation
desmond toutou le prix nobel de la paix
est une trentaine de protestataires ont
été interpellés
interrogé puis relâché l'organisation
lyonnaise handicap international annonce
un retour imminent de xavier le mini
c'est le kinésithérapeute français
détenus en afghanistan au liban
la diplomatie est sur la touche les
duels
artillerie ont fait ces dernières 24
heures dix-sept morts tous civils à
l'est et à l'ouest
d'autres informations à l'étranger
philippe bois serait festivités
grandioses pour les 20 ans de pouvoir du
colonel kadhafi
le chef d'état libyen a rallumé la
flamme révolutionnaire de son livre vert
pour lui la libye plus forte que jamais
n'abandonnera pas les opprimés luttant
pour leur liberté
un message adressé au nicaragua à la
palestine mais aussi à la nouvelle
calédonie une vingtaine de chefs d'état
du tiers monde ont salué celui qui avait
détrôné le roi idriss le 1er septembre
parmi eux le président syrien et yasser
arafat assis côte à côte
francisco rodriguez nommé nouveau
président du panama après l'annulation
des élections présidentielles de mai
dernier
le général noriega place un de ses
fidèles à la tête du gouvernement
l'opposition par le
d'inconstitutionnalité et de coup de
force contre le peuple
les etats unis envisagent de nouvelles
sanctions et dénonce une fois encore
manuel noriega
selon washington le trafic de drogue il
y aurait permis d'amasser une fortune de
près de 2 milliards de francs
alerte rouge en colombie après le réveil
du nevada del ruiz l'éruption volcanique
provoque la fonte des neiges et de
gigantesques coulées de boue pour
l'instant aucune victime n'est à
déplorer mais tout le monde se souvient
de l'irruption de 1985 25000 personnes
avaient péri englouti armero l'historien
soviétique afanassiev écrit l'histoire
ne se refait pas elle s'assume c'est
peut-être ce que tente actuellement le
kremlin en faisant visiter à des caméras
de l'ouest des camps du goulag ce que
vous allez voir est exceptionnel et
exclusif antenne 2 nous sommes en pleine
sibérie au nord du lac baïkal au camp 32
la vive 2500 prisonniers officiellement
ce sont tous des droits communs ce
reportage est signé par michel honorin
et alain poirier
aucun 32 6 heures du matin mettez vous
ça vous arrange les prisonniers vont
sortir tout autour
et
quand vous
vous souhaitez perdre et je suis là
depuis 14 ans 14en quand ils enchantent
irait jamais je suis devenu selon ce que
vous voyez sortie en 90 sorties en 98
sorti en 94
dans quelques minutes c'est l'heure de
la vis location pour le départ au
travail
il se fout de vous dire celui applicable
ne vous montrent que le dessus de la
casserole allez donc là-bas à l'aise du
camp ce qui ne vous montreront pas saint
alphonse
demande au colonel on nous conduit à
l'aise du camp ce et le mitard pas de
l'ifad sur fifa ce travail pendant un an
à l'extérieur seul appel pour le travail
18h45 il y à 2510 ailleurs
non je m'en réjouis
l'intégralité de ce document exclusif
sur l'univers carcéral soviétique un
document d'une heure sera diffusée sur
antenne 2 dans les prochains jours
lionel jospin fait de la lutte contre
l'échec scolaire la philosophie de cette
rentrée 89 dans sa conférence de presse
le ministre de l'éducation donne comme
objectif aux enseignants d'apprendre à
lire à écrire et à compter aux enfants
avant la sixième l'évaluation des élèves
se fera systématiquement et les remises
à niveau dans le primaire devrait se
faire en douceur sans redoublement pour
la première fois cette année dans le
primaire cent cinquante mille enfants
apprendront une langue étrangère
à noter que près de 6000 postes
d'enseignants ont été créés et que
chaque établissement devra veiller à
réfléchir sur un projet pédagogique
notre dossier du jour les manuels
scolaires ils sont gratuits pour les
élèves mais le chiffre d'affaires des
éditions scolaires et de 1,7 milliard de
francs au trois quart financé par l'état
en fait il y a là une véritable jungle
dans laquelle les enseignants ne se
retrouvent pas toujours
monique atlan l'édition scolaire une
véritable jungle où les professeurs qui
choisissent les livres ont bien du mal à
se retrouver ainsi d'une année sur
l'autre on leur présente parfois comme
nouveauté des manuels qui en réalité
change simplement de titres ou de
couverture si vous comparez ces deux
livres de grammaire duo même auteur dans
l'édition de 1982 et dans celle de 1987
on peut constater que les leçons une
bonne partie des lotions sont
strictement identiques
vous avez aussi un livre de lecture de
magna qui s'appelle en 1978 enfance de
provence du languedoc et dont le fichier
de la bibliothèque nationale signal
les précédemment paru sous le titre
enfonce du midi vous avez le catalogue
larousse qui présente l année dernière
un aide mémoire pour l'école primaire
qui est devenu cette année sur le
programme du primaire
en fait c'est le même livre vous avez la
même présentation et le même commentaire
et vous avez dans le tarif la même
référence qui prouve bien que on a
affaire un seul livre des pratiques qui
si elles ne sont pas quotidiennes sont
révélatrices de ce nécessaire dont
bénéficient les éditeurs une preuve il
n'y a pas de responsable spécifique des
livres scolaires au ministère personnes
pour évaluer leur qualité ou leur
conformité au programme il n'y a pas de
manuels ni de pédagogie officiel les
équipes enseignantes ont par conséquent
le choix de leurs supports pédagogiques
comme il n'y a pas de manuel officiel
l'édition des manuels scolaires est une
activité privée non concurrence et par
l'administration
côté éditeurs ont choisi d'ignorer les
accusations on reconnaît les
dysfonctionnements et on renvoie la
responsabilité dans le corps de
l'éducation nationale tous les
dysfonctionnements se ramène à ces deux
causes instabilité des programmes
nous sommes en 1989 à la fin de la
réforme
chevènement monory et on parle déjà de
réformes jospin quand cela
s'arrêtera-t-il précipitation des
décisions les décisions concernant la
mise en oeuvre de nouveaux programmes
sont prises beaucoup trop rapidement
avant la parution des ouvrages doux
erreur oublie omission confusion entre
laisser-faire confus et contrôles
tatillons une solution est sans doute à
trouver dont dépend un meilleur système
scolaire et la nuit au dont on vous a
parlé dans ce reportage et qui a écrit
un livre qui s'appelle dans la jungle
des manuels scolaires est l'invité ce
soir de bernard pivot à 21h30 dans
apostrophes et lionel jospin le ministre
de l'éducation et lui l'invité de
l'heure de vérité qui rentre lundi à
20h30 sur internet feuilleton maradona
suit normalement d'après les derniers
télégrammes que nous avons reçues
d'amérique du sud diego maradona doit
prendre l'avion ce soir pour madrid et
demain
il devrait faire un vol entre madrid et
rome quant à sa venue à marseille
toujours pas d'autres nouvelles
il est attendu là-bas à 90% sur ses
ultimes péripéties
voyons cela avec jean ma mère même si
l'intermédiaire france elle a annoncé
maradona n'est pas encore à marseille à
naples ça bouge
l'arrivée de la star prévue pour demain
via madrid laisse tout le monde
dubitatif
en revanche au club le porte parole
annonce la saisie de la société créée
pour exploiter l'image du joueur et dans
laquelle maradona bien sûr à beaucoup
d'intérêt les dirigeants napolitains
sont désormais loin des accolades et se
disent toujours prêt à interdire
maradona de jouer par tous les moyens
de toute façon même s'il vient à
marseille les problèmes ne sont pas pour
autant résolus une star chasse l'autre
et il faudra bien qu'un autre étranger
vadel ou moser laisse la place pas
facile et puis au fait
maradona est il vraiment souhaité à
marseille il ya quand même le doute qui
le coeur qui met la panique est bien là
où il est oui mais voilà maradona lui
n'est pas bien là où il est et ce ne
sont pas que de simples prière qui vont
dénouer sans affaire pronostic de
pierrette brès pour le tiercé demain à
vincennes voici dix-huit le 1 le 16 le
13 le 12 4
le 15 et le 11 dans un instant laurent
cabrol pour la météo dernier journal
avec un but signé ce week-end les
informations seront signés par betty
dureau daniel bilalian et philippe
gassot fin de ce journal
excellente soirée à tous sur antenne 2